Bit Torrent has several steps for publishing. First,
a peer creates what's called a torrent which contains
metadata about tracker and all of the pieces of
the file in question as well as a checksum
for each piece of the file at the time
the torrent was created. Now some peers in the
network need to maintain a complete initial copy of
the file. Those peers are called seeders. Now to
download a file, a client first contacts
the tracker which provides this metadata about
the file, including a list of seeders that contain an initial copy of the file.
Next, the client starts to download parts of the file from the seeder. Once
the client starts to accumulate some initial
chunks, hopefully those chunks were different than those
that other clients in the network that are also trading the file have. At this
point clients can begin to swap chuncks.
As clients begin swapping distinct chunks with one
another, the idea is that eventually after
enough swapping everyone gets a copy of the
complete file. Clients that contain incomplete copies of
the file are called leechers. The tracker allows
peers to find each other and it also returns a random list of peers that any
particular leecher can use to swap chunks of
the file. Previous, peer to peer file-sharing systems used
similar swapping techniques, but a problem that many
of them faced, and which Bit Torrent solved, is
called free-loading, whereby a client might leave the
network as soon as it finished. downloading a copy
of the file, not providing any benefit to other clients who also want the file.